It's been a really good start to 2016 from the point of view of the periodic table.
IUPAC, the International Union of Pure and Applied Chemistry,
has confirmed the existence of four new elements.
So if you look at the periodic table here,
we have elements 113, 115, 117, 118, that have no names at the moment.
They have symbols – Uup meaning 115 – but they don't have a real name.
And what's happened is not new experiments,
but the committees looking at the experimental evidence have decided
that those elements really have been synthesised and are real.
So in a way, it's a bit like giving a prize to the people who've done the experiments,
to say, "You've got it right."
Before we go into possible names for these elements,
let me just remind you, if you haven't watched our videos before,
how you make these elements.
If you look at the periodic table, all the elements
that are heavier than uranium, number 92,
all of these are highly radioactive,
and as you go along the periodic table they become more and more radioactive.
Even if you have some atoms, they decay in  fractions of a second, or just a few seconds.
So you can't dig them out of the ground, you have to make them.
And the way you make them is by taking a lighter atom
– but which is still quite heavy –
and bombarding that material with lighter atoms.
You do this so billions of light atoms hit every second.
And then every so often, perhaps once a week, for difficult elements, once a month,
one of these atoms fuses into the other one.
So you can see it's quite a hard process.
(My dog toy is getting a bit old...)
So now you have a combined nucleus.
For example, we have element 95, americium,
plus element calcium, 20.
20 plus 95 makes 115,
and bingo! You get an atom of the element.
Of course, this atom is quite unstable.
so you detect it by watching it decay.
These elements here have been discovered in different labs,
usually but not always as a collaboration between two different laboratories.
And you have to understand that these are such specialised experiments
that you will only find one suitable lab in a particular country,
and often, most countries don't even have such labs.
So, element 113 was first discovered in a lab in Japan.
We have a video in Japanese about it for our Japanese viewers.
[Clip of Sir Martyn, dubbed over in Japanese]
And the other elements here – 115, 117, 118 –
were collaborations between a US lab and the research center in Dubna, near Moscow.
And so the experiments were done in Dubna, but the precursors, the radioactive materials like berkelium,
which were the heavy element that we crashed into,
were prepared in America and flown over.
Now, you have to understand that the way that IUPAC operates
is that after the first lab has done the experiments,
they require somebody else to do the repeat of the experiments to make sure the first ones are right.
So although, for example, I might have done the first experiments,
(I don't synthesise any elements, but just as an example)
then somebody else will confirm my results.
So it's only polite, and I think nice, to talk to the other people before choosing a name.
There are certain rules. You can name it after places, countries, people.
But the important thing is, the person has to be a scientist who's dead.
My feeling is – and I have no idea what the name is going to be! –
but I think element 113 is likely to have a Japanese name,
because the Japanese lab RIKEN has been told they can choose the name.
There is a fruit, which some of you may know, called japonica,
so you could imagine a name something like japonicium, based on Japan.
It would have the symbol Jp.
"J" doesn't appear on the periodic table yet, so that would be a really nice first.
Sometimes Germans call iodine by the letter J, but most periodic tables don't have a J.
There is some Internet chatter, and I've heard rumors that 115 will be called moscovium, after Moscow.
I think that would be really good, though of course the symbol Mo has already gone, for molybdenum.
I like moscovium because my father was born in Moscow.
I have also suggested that element 117 should be called – after Richard Feynman, the famous physicist –
feynmanium, but some viewers already said that feynamnium should be left for element 132,
which Feynman predicted might be stable.
So we'll have to see.
I feel, probably, that the most thought will be given by people to element 118,
because that's the highest number currently on the periodic table.
And I have no idea what they will choose!
You will see all over the press, people saying "The periodic table is now complete!"
Which, in a way, it is, that we have finished this row of the periodic table, the seventh row.
As you go down: one, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
But I see this just as a beginning!
The field is now open!
Can physicists now synthesise elements which will start row number eight, down here?
The first element that's likely to be synthesised is 120,
because even-numbered elements are more stable than odd-numbered elements.
And so it would be really interesting to see whether one of these elements can be made soon.
The periodic table is always waiting for new results!
In fact, we already have a video about the possibility of element 120, which you can watch if you're interested.
Chemistry is not finished! This is just the beginning, and I hope that 2016 is going to be a really exciting year
for chemistry and for science in general.
So again, happy new year to you all, great success in your science, and keep watching!